erleichterungen für geimpfte während der
bund noch im ungefähren bleibt preschen
länder wie bayern mit konkreten vorgaben
voraus am anfang eines aufschwungs in
der wirtschaft läuft es besser als
gedacht meint die regierung und
korrigiert ihre frühjahrsprognose nach
oben
ein sehr teurer trainer julian
nagelsmann geht zu den bayern und bringt
seinem noch verein leipzig angeblich 25
millionen euro ablöse
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen heute 19 uhr an diesem
dienstag zusammen mit norbert lehmann
für den sport einen schönen gruß von mir
wie immer gab es große erwartungen an
den impf gipfel von bund und ländern
gestern bekommen zweimal geimpfte nun
bald ihr altes leben zurück und wird
beim impfen jetzt ohne starre
reihenfolge richtig aufs tempo gedrückt
doch konkrete beschlüsse fehlanzeige
dafür preschen jetzt einzelne länder vor
und stellen geimpften wie negativ
getesteten erleichterungen in aussicht
wie bayern und hessen zum beispiel klaus
brodbeck berichtet so schnell ging es
bei corona gipfeln zuletzt selten
trotzdem was erleichterung an geht nicht
schnell genug beklagt nicht nur die
opposition
wir sagen wenn kein infektionsrisiko von
menschen ausgeht dann darf ihre freiheit
nicht eingeschränkt werden wenn die
begründung weggefallen ist und die
menschen nicht mehr ansteckend sind und
es also keine gefahr mehr für die für
das für das leben der öffentlichkeit ist
dann kann man natürlich ihre grundrechte
nicht einschränkt wir müssen sehr viel
schneller entscheiden wir müssen sehr
viel schneller dafür sorgen dass die
grundrechte zurückkehren an diejenigen
die sie haben und dass wir für kinder
und familien mit tests und mit
impfmöglichkeiten auch eine echte
perspektive bieten auch kommunen und
landkreise fordern den stufenplan zurück
zu mehr normalität
wir brauchen da mehr klarheit im
hinblick auf die stufen plan und ich
kann nur hoffen und und dringlich darum
bitten dass sich die bundesregierung mit
dem minister sind an der stelle klar
vereinbart
je mehr menschen vollständig geimpft
sind desto problematischer werden
grundrechts einschränkungen schon ab
morgen versprechen zwei länder für diese
gruppe erleichterungen deswegen haben
wir heute auch beschlossen
im vorgriff auf die bundesverordnung das
können wir machen bei zwei mal geimpft
mehr zweimal geimpft ist muss ab morgen
keine tests mehr vorlegen
in allen bereichen in denen bisher tests
erforderlich waren werden vollständig
geimpften diesen getesteten personen
gleichgestellt
es braucht dann keinen test und das
heißt zum beispiel beim friseur oder
weil ein grau oder bei den quarantäne
regeln bisher geplant ist dass ende mai
bundesweite erleichterungen beschlossen
werden sollen könnte wohl auch früher
werden
da fragen wir theo koll in berlin
theophil kritik also für den impf gipfel
weil so wenig dabei heraus kam und nun
die länder wieder ihr eigenes ding
machen warum hat das gestern nicht
besser funktioniert ja das war gestern
eher ein virtueller stuhlkreis als eine
entscheidungsgremium und einige
teilnehmer sagen so war es auch trotz
des großen titels impfgipfel immer
gedacht was es aber natürlich nicht
besser macht denn auch beim thema rechte
und freiheiten von geimpften gilt ja
keine entscheidung ist ja auch eine
entscheidung wenn sich also jetzt erst
ende mai der bundesrat damit
abschließend befassen soll
dann heißt es eben auch bis dahin hat
man stillschweigend entschieden
vollständig geimpften die entzogenen
rechte weiterhin vorzuenthalten und auch
deshalb erleben wir jetzt dass einzelne
bundesländer verbrechen und die
freiheiten die freiheiten die auf
länderebene geregelt werden dürfen auch
schon entscheiden das dann
beispielsweise für geimpfte im
einzelhandel oder beim friseurbesuch
keinen negativen test mehr vorlegen zu
müssen anderes aber wie die aufhebung
der ausgangsbedingungen für geimpfte das
kann nur der bund regeln und da gilt
dann bis auf weiteres nicht erlaubt
durch die noch immer nicht entscheidung
vielen dank für die einordnung theo koll
in berlin war dass wir mehr menschen
geimpft sind desto lebhafter wird über
lockerungen für sie diskutiert aktuell
haben laut robert-koch-institut rund
19,9 millionen menschen die erste dosis
erhalten das sind 23 9 prozent
zweimal geimpft sind rund sechs
millionen menschen also
7,3 prozent jetzt werden forderungen
laut die betriebsärzte schneller
einzubinden stefan kelch mit beispielen
aus sachsen und baden württemberg
das pilotprojekt startet zwar heute aber
sie haben sich bei liebherr in ehingen
schon geraume zeit auf diesen tag
vorbereitet
wir haben eine eigene pc testmaschine
hier
wir starten jeden mitarbeiter so aus
dass er sich jeden tag zu hause testen
kann
und natürlich impfen jetzt als die
finale lösung um aus der krise
herauszukommen und das in einem eigenen
impfzentrum gleich neben der produktion
ab heute nun testbetrieb um zu sehen ob
alles so läuft wie sich die
betriebsärzte das vorgestellt haben
dieser phase haben sie bei vw in zwickau
auch schon hinter sich
sie haben das gesundheitszentrum zum im
zentrum umgebaut und ein impf mobil auf
die reise zu den anderen sächsischen
produktionsstandorten geschickt noch
besseres oder positiv was kommt
eigentlich leben direkt von der arbeit
eigentlich vordringt geimpft werden
dürfen sonst oder zu können
ich denke ich was besseres gibt es nicht
die vw ärzte entscheiden nachdem
priorisierungen regeln wer jetzt geimpft
wird über eine hotline hatten die ärzte
mit den kollegen im vorfeld kontakt ja
haben sie individuelle beratungen
bekommen zu ihrem krankheitsbildern ob
ein besonderes risiko besteht der
betriebsrat hat in diesem prozess ein
wachsames auge vor allem auf den
datenschutz gehabt die ärzte das
medizinische personal fällt unter die
schweigepflicht das heißt das angebot
wird nur direkt zwischen medizinischen
zentrum und dem kollegen oder
kolleginnen gesprochen das infomobil von
vw steht aber nicht nur autobauern zur
verfügung mit den impfdosen des drk und
in dessen auftrag wertes durch ganz
sachsen die betriebsärzte impfen künftig
überall wo das drk unterstützung braucht
mehr rechte für geimpfte was bei uns
noch diskutiert wird ist in anderen
ländern längst gängige praxis
boge impfte welche freiheiten genießen
können sie in der zdf- heute- app
nachlesen
die zahl der korona neue infekt
in deutschland ist nach wie vor hoch das
robert koch institut meldet zehn 1976
neue positivtests binnen 24 stunden das
sind 1367 mehr als vergangenen dienstag
344 todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sieben tage incidents sinkt leicht
auf 167,6 trotz der weiter ernsten
coroner lage erwartet die
bundesregierung eine stärkere wirtschaft
und hob ihre wachstumsprognose für
dieses jahr an von 3,0 auf 3,5 prozent
bundeswirtschaftsminister altmaier setzt
vor allem auf exporte und will schon im
nächsten jahr die alte stärke wieder
erreicht haben patricia biedermeier
berichtet stolz zeigt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister nach einer
erneuten delle zu anfang des jahres gehe
ist jetzt bergauf altmaier hebt die
prognose für das wirtschaftswachstum in
diesem jahr an auf 3,5 prozent
dieses jahr ist das jahr in dem wir die
trendwende enthüllt die schaffen
wir werden den wirtschaftseinbruch nicht
nur stoppen sondern wir werden ihn
umkehren
wir haben spätestens 2022 wieder die
alte stärke erreicht
es ist vor allem eine robuste
weltwirtschaft in den usa und in china
die kräftig waren made in germany
nachfragt und je mehr lockerungen es in
den nächsten monaten gebe wenn auch
gastronomie und einzelhandel wieder
aufmachen dann so altmaier werde auch
die binnennachfrage zu nehmen mit einer
großen insolvenzwelle rechnet er nicht
anders als die opposition
viele unternehmen stehen vor der
insolvenz wenn jetzt die
insolvenzantrags frist ausläuft
insbesondere in der hotellerie in der
gastronomie in der reisebranche aber
auch bei den veranstaltungs anbietern
zahlreiche insolvenzen um genau das zu
verhindern beschloss das kabinett heute
zudem den deutschen aufbau plan ein
programm für aufschwung und neue
arbeitsplätze
insgesamt gibt es ca 28 milliarden euro
aus dem corona wiederaufbau von der eu
elf milliarden davon für den klimaschutz
14 milliarden für die digitale
transformation spätestens im jahr 2050
wollen wie klima nord
erwirtschaften wir investieren deshalb
40 prozent der finanzmittel in
klimafreundliche mobilität in
wasserstoff technologie und in die
gebäudesanierung die botschaft der
regierung deutschlands wirtschaft ist
bereit für den neustart fragt sich nur
wann genau es wirklich so weit ist
der münchner kardinal marx verzichtet
auf den verdienstorden der
bundesrepublik in einem brief an
bundespräsident steinmeier verweist er
auf die kritik an der für morgen
geplanten verleihung durch
missbrauchsopfer
sie hatten ihm vorgeworfen die
aufklärung verschleppt zu haben
mit seinem verzicht so kardinal marx
hoffe er nun ein zeichen setzen zu
können dass ihm die aufarbeitung
sexuellen missbrauchs ein wichtiges
anliegen bleiben steinmeier respektierte
die entscheidung missbrauchs betroffene
begrüßte den verzicht
wer ein bankkonto besitzt kennt ss
kompost mit seitenlangen änderungen der
allgemeinen geschäftsbedingungen
wenn man dann keinen widerspruch einlegt
gilt das als zustimmung etwa auch zu
höheren gebühren
damit ist nun schluss der
bundesgerichtshof entschied die klauseln
benachteiligten die kunden unangemessen
das tauziehen um den exit dauerte monate
lang gerade noch rechtzeitig im alten
jahr an heiligabend einigten sich die eu
staaten und großbritannien auf ein
handels- und kooperationsabkommen
doch weil die eu-abgeordneten zeit
brauchten die 1400 seiten zu prüfen galt
es erst mal nur übergangsweise bis ende
april
heute nun soll das parlament für die
vereinbarung stimmen
am ersten mai würde der handelstag dann
in kraft treten
viele probleme aber bleiben aus brüssel
anne gellinek ein letzter applaus für
michel barnier den nun ehemaligen rexit
chefverhandler der eu vier einheit zehn
jahre hatte er mit großbritannien
gerungen er ist um das scheidungs
abkommen und dann um den handelsvertrag
der noch am abend abgestimmt wird
so soll die woche schließt eine
scheidung der brh exit ist eine warnung
und ein versagen auch der europäischen
union wir sollten daraus lernen
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
warb am morgen um die zustimmung der
parlamentarier der handelspakt gebe der
eu die möglichkeit auch einseitig
strafzölle zu verhängen dich griem
endkampf das abkommen hat wirklich zähne
wir wollen diese instrumente nicht
anwenden aber wir werden auch nicht
zögern sie wenn nötig zu nutzen
es herrscht misstrauen zwischen
großbritannien und der eu vor allem
wegen des nordirland protokolls damit
der fragile frieden auf der insel nicht
in gefahr gerät soll es keine
grenzkontrollen zwischen dem britischen
nordirland und der republik irland geben
stattdessen sollen die briten güter auf
eu standards überprüfen die sie per
schiff nach nordirland bringen
boris johnson aber hat die kontrollen
einseitig ausgesetzt schon mehrfach kam
es in nordirland zu krawallen
die die für eine enge bindung mit
großbritannien eintreten sehen dass
nordirland protokoll als verrat den
theaterdonner sein zu lassen sondern
wirklich zu vereinbarung zu stehen und
nicht noch zusätzlich öl ins feuer zu
gießen
zähneknirschend werden die
europa-parlamentarier dem handelsvertrag
am abend wohl trotzdem zustimmen
die brics it saga ist damit noch nicht
zu ende was passiert wenn corona außer
kontrolle gerät zeigt sich gerade in
indien das gesundheitssystem kollabiert
mehrere länder schicken hilfe auch
deutschland seit mitte märz steigt die
zahl der neuinfektionen steil an
mehrere hunderttausend kommen
mittlerweile jeden tag dazu
und die dunkelziffer dürfte hoch sein
allein gestern wurden mehr als 2700
todesfälle gemeldet
normen odenthal über eine dramatische
situation krematorien braucht das land
es sind zu viele tote an jedem einzelnen
tag und neuinfektionen wieder mehr als
320.000 in nur 24 stunden
die entwicklung schockiert ein ganzes
land wird zum notfall
wir haben ähnliche infektions verläufe
in anderen staaten erlebt aber doch
nicht in diesem ausmaß und nicht mit
dieser belastenden auswirkungen auf das
gesamte gesundheitssystem wie jetzt in
indien droht der kollaps oder ist er
schon da das virus nimmt die luft zum
atmen sauerstoff fehlt betten fehlen und
vielen fehlt inzwischen auch die
hoffnung alle krankenhäuser haben uns
weggeschickt keiner hilft uns alles ist
am ende alles
die regierung verspricht viel aber
sauerstoff gibt es nur auf dem
schwarzmarkt bilder aus den vergangenen
tagen dasselbe land wie ein anderer
planet massenversammlung auf religiösen
festen oder bei kommunalwahlen ist das
leicht sind sorglosigkeit in jedem fall
ist es lebensgefährlich
wir sind alle unvorsichtig geworden weil
wir zu beginn des jahres so geringe
fallzahlen hatten wir haben
fälschlicherweise geglaubt die partie
nur sei schon vor über impfen scheint
die rettung auch dafür müssen sie
schlange stehen dicht an dicht und
manchmal nur um kurz vor dem ziel den
nächsten rückschlag zu erlegen
bitte geht nach hause der impfstoff ist
alle bitte geht jetzt folgt den
anweisungen der polizei
ihr müsst kooperieren die
gesundheitsbehörden rufen dazu auf
masken nun auch zu hause zu tragen
nirgendwo scheint man mehr sicher delhi
mumbai die großen metropolen verschärfen
den lockdown wer die regeln bricht wird
zu kniebeugen verdonnert es ist zu ernst
und darüber zu schmunzeln die
bundesregierung verurteilt einen
tätlichen angriff auf journalisten vor
dem kanzleramt
regierungssprecher seibert sagte
journalismus müsse in deutschland ohne
angst ausgeübt werden können
gestern hatten fünf personen den
reporter und sein kamerateam von welt.tv
während einer live schalte attackiert
die berichterstattung wurde daraufhin
abgebrochen
die polizei nahm vier randalierer
vorläufig fest
mit dem sogenannten nationalen
radverkehrs wegeplan 3.0 soll vieles
besser werden vor allem die sicherheit
für radfahrende der bund gibt geld etwa
für rad schnell wege oder eigen
fahrrad brücken im autoland deutschland
heißt das in vielen städten muss
umgedacht werden zb am ort des
radverkehrs kongresses in hamburg
ralf zimmermann von seefahrt informiert
noch ist hamburg weit davon entfernt die
perfekte fahrradstadt zu sein
dabei wird ziemlich hart an dem
entsprechenden image gearbeitet und der
umbau vom auto als nummer eins zum
fahrrad als nummer eins findet viel
zustimmung auch unter autofahrern
ich finde man kann inzwischen schon
besser fahrradfahren und ja autofahren
bringen zunehmend keinen spaß mehr
mehr fahrrad wäre breitere und sichere
fahrradwege auf kosten der autofahrer
war auf kosten aller bürger auf kosten
der steuerzahler 1,5 milliarden euro
will der bund in den nächsten zwei
jahren in die fahrrad infrastruktur
investieren oder bezuschussen
diese botschaft brachte der heute mal
radelnde bundesverkehrsminister zum
nationalen rat kongress mit durchaus zur
freude des grünen hamburger verkehrs
senators
das ist wichtiges geld um die rad
verkehrsinfrastruktur in deutschland zu
verbessern aber man muss natürlich auch
gucken das wichtigste ziel dass
überhaupt ein lückenloses
radverkehrsnetz herzustellen das
bedeutet umgekehrt wir haben das
momentan noch nicht das heißt es gibt
auch noch wirklich viel zu tun
ein nationale radverkehrsplan geht nur
verkehrsträgerübergreifend stadt im
gegeneinander im miteinander und es geht
deutlich ambitionierter allerdings
dürften die ziele schon sein meint die
fahrradlobby angesichts dieser trauten
einigkeit dass auf jeden fall notwendig
ist es eine langfristige finanzierung
die also nicht nur bis 2023 sondern
solche großen infrastrukturprojekte wie
städte umzubauen und tatsächlich
fahrradfreundlich zu machen die müssen
langfristig geplant werden immer wieder
thema die rad verkehrssicherheit 2009 10
etwas sterben deutschlandweit fast 450
menschen allein beim fahrradfahren
so sind großstädte wie hamburg trotz man
schnell markierten radweg mit ihren
anstrengungen noch lange nicht am ziel
und nun zur fußball-bundesliga und zum
teuersten trainerwechsel der geschichte
juliana ritzmann der leipzig coach der
wechselt ja zum saisonende nach münchen
von 20 bis 30 millionen euro ablöse ist
da die rede
die bayern lassen sich ihren
wunschkandidaten als nachfolger für
hansi flick also einiges kosten
zwei jahre früher als vertraglich
vereinbart verlässt julian nagelsmann rb
leipzig das gesamtpaket ist einfach ein
besonderes und für andere klubs hätte
ich diesen vertrag nicht beendet
grundsätzlich habe ich ja oder waren sie
gespräche gut sie waren für sie waren
offen auch von mir offen und demnach
glaube ich
hat das nichts mit vertragsbruch oder
sonstige dinge zu tun und damit dem oral
verträge zu erfüllen noch trainiert
nagelsmann leipzig und natürlich
erwartet man dort eine fortsetzung der
erfolgreichen saison
wir wollen die rekord saison spielen wir
wollen natürlich zwingend ins
pokalfinale und das pokalfinale gewinnen
und natürlich auch zweiter werden
hinter bayern münchen das in der
nächsten saison wieder einen top trainer
auf der bank sitzen hat heute abend das
erste halbfinal hinspiel in der fußball
champions league die königlichen treffen
auf die blues real madrid in
bestechender form 17 pflichtspiele in
folge ungeschlagen chelsea trainer
thomas tuchel der noch optimistisch wir
glauben dass jetzt der richtige moment
gekommen ist dieses spiel zu spielen
wir werden hungrig spielen mit
abenteuerlust und vielleicht nicht mit
der halbfinal erfahrung das kompensieren
wir aber mit hunger und mit enthusiasmus
der krisengeplagte dfb kommt nicht zur
ruhe nachdem präsident fritz keller
seinen vize rainer koch mit einem nazi
richter verglichen haben soll steht der
64 jährige mächtig unter druck
kritik kommt aus landesverbänden und von
der dfl
bevor erst 19 monaten ist fritz keller
angetreten den größten einzel
sportfachverband der welt in ruhigere
fahrwasser zu führen
jetzt bereitet sein nazi-vergleich den
dfb nach steuerermittlungen und
zahllosen intrigen das nächste problem
daran ändert auch seine entschuldigung
nichts
manchmal fallen den kontroversen worte
die nicht fallen sollen noch nicht
fallen dürfen dafür habe ich mich in
aller form persönlichen gespräch wie
auch schriftlich bei rainer koch
entschuldigt insbesondere auch im
hinblick auf die opfer des
nationalsozialismus war der vergleich
gänzlich unangebracht nazi richter
fässler hatte mehr als
zweieinhalbtausend todesurteile unter
anderem an den geschwistern scholl
vollstrecken lassen über den bayerischen
fußballverband ließ vizepräsident koch
ausrichten er habe die entschuldigung
bislang nicht angenommen weil er den
gesamten vorgang mit zeitlichem abstand
zunächst in einem persönlichen gespräch
mit fritz keller aufarbeiten möchte
jetzt ermittelt die ethikkommission ob
nach wolfgang niersbach und reinhard
grindel auch der dritte die die
präsident vorzeitig gehen muss
eishockey nationalspieler leon
dreiseitel hat den deutschen scorer
rekord in der nordamerikanischen profi
liga nhl gebrochen
der kölner steuerte zum 6 zu 1 seiner
edmonton oilers gegen die winnipeg jets
ein tor und einen assist bei und kommt
damit auf 488 scorerpunkte der
hauptrunde
das ist ein zähler mehr als der
bisherige deutsche rekordhalter ich mag
ich danke norbert und wir haben noch
einen rekord für sie den größten und
hellsten vollmond des jahres nämlich
auch super mond genannt näher kommt er
auf seiner elliptischen umlaufbahn der
erde nie und erscheint dann besonders
groß und leuchtet wenn die wolken
mitspielen ist dass auf der ganzen welt
wunderschön anzusehen in dresden genauso
wie zb in new york heute nacht lohnt
sich der blick noch mal ja und morgen
scheint dann wieder die sonne
erst zum abend kommt dann von westen her
regen wie lange und wie sehr es regnet
das weiß gleich katja honnef das war es
von uns schön dass sie dabei waren
marietta slomka erwartet sie um viertel
vor zehn zum heute journal
und wir hoffen dass sie morgen wieder
einschalten um 19 uhr einen schönen
abend noch machen sie es gut
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren der
wirkungsbereich von hoch sandra
erstreckte sich heute von südschweden
über dänemark und polen und deutschland
bis weit nach frankreich über
großbritannien drehte sich dagegen ein
wolken wirbel
und auch hier südlich der alpen sehen
sie viele wollten aber nicht bei uns und
das bleibt auch heute nacht so da gibt
es höchstens mal lockere wolkenfelder
ganz im norden
sie können also nochmal nach dem super
mond ausschau halten bei temperaturen
zwischen 5 grad am oberrhein oder auch
auf den ostfriesischen inseln und minus
ein grad in den mittelgebirgen morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen an der
küste immerhin schon mal bei 12 oder 13
grad sonst sind es 15 bis 17 und sie
lästig von sauerland rhön und thüringer
wald sogar 18 bis 22 grad
der tag startet erst nur mit viel sonne
und nur kleinen quellwolken das ändert
sich dann zum nachmittag dann werden die
wolken von südwesten immer dichter und
bringen die ersten regenschauer mit die
dann schon in der nacht weiter nach
nordosten ziehen
das ist bestimmt gut für alle die gerade
unter pollenallergie leiden denn derzeit
sind besonders die birken und die eschen
pollen in großer konzentration unterwegs
am donnerstag gibt es dann häufig
schauer und gewitter und anbrach geht es
wechselhaft weiter bei neun bis 20 grad
schöner